in the Yukon oh whoa
whoa there's no such thing as a typical
family oh that's scary she looks like a
swamp monster no no hugging no hugging
and no matter how crazy things get
waa watch I'll get you don't let him out
don't let him out Dr Oakley knows her
family will always be there Mom the cast
off what cast off all right don't let
him run around
Dr Michelle Oakley's home Clinic helps
all animals big and small here patients
feel like family Michelle helps many
neighbors who stop by no matter how foul
turkey turkey who do you have here
skimpy so Lydia came in walking her
turkey and her cat carrier she's one of
Willow's besties and she's so interested
in animals she has a whole herd of other
Critters at home so what happened with
skimpy broken leg oh no even though
she's definitely a farm girl and she
knows these turkeys are being raised for
food Lydia and I are on the same page
while they're being raised they should
be comfortable they should be taken care
of when did it happen I'm pretty sure it
was yesterday actually really okay
skimpy what's going on here thanks to
Lydia this one-month-old chick narrowly
escaped The Chopping Block my dad said
that we have a turkey with a broken leg
and I have to put him down this
afternoon I said no we had to take him
to Dr Michelle to fix him cuz I think I
thought he would be able to live
instead oh yeah that's not working that
one's not working I
know this leg here assisting with the
turkey exam is vettech Lindsay Palmer oh
goodness oh my goodness it's so sore so
do you want to just wait out there and
then I'll I'll tell you when we're done
okay y I'm actually just going to use a
little bit of gas anesthesia to mask it
down so that I can look at its leg
carefully and move it around without it
feeling any pain you stay there skimpy
but none of Michelle's instruments were
designed with turkey chicks in mind it's
time for a little Yukon Ingenuity skimpy
so tiny so you can see we just did a
little adaptation to the Mas we just put
a piece of a of a rubber glove there of
an exam glove and that keeps nostrils
and mouth in there okay skimpy with
skimpy snoozing peacefully they can
begin a more thorough exam
that does not feel right you can see
it's popping in and out you see thaton
okay there definitely was an injury and
he needs a splint on his leg and of
course I don't have a splint for a
turkey leg they don't even make splints
for turkey legs
ohm little finger splint nice we decided
to use a finger splint for a human like
a person's finger and attach it to
skimpy leg and that'll have to do needs
to be shortened a bit just to touch yeah
y Conor and Alaskan folks in general are
resourceful they have to be you can't
just order up parts or things you need
and get them the next day you got to be
little creative Bend snip twist fit the
turkey leg teeny tiny drumstick he's got
the Oakley turkey splint yes yes I think
that's going to work just dandy patent
pending and now we can wake the turkey
up there we go there we go there we go
perfect okay Lydia do you want come in
and bring his crate he's still going to
have a tough time getting around I think
at first mhm young birds grow fast and
heal fast so skimpy should be ready to
lose the splint in a week or
so I don't know what her dad's going to
say about having a turkey in the house
that's actually what I'm going to
recommend is he is he stay in a small
cage in the house for the next week
until he can go back out there
scratching and pecking we'll be in touch
you and Willow will be checking in on
this thing every day I'm sure yeah okay
okay thank you Michelle bye he's got the
perfect nurse at hand and that's Lydia
so you should do just fine may go home
[Music]
skimpy it's a family affair for Dr
Oakley her parents are her support
system through thick and thin today
they're here to cheer her on as she
takes on a big
case got to have my
coffee got to be fully caffeinated if
you're dealing with muscs Michelle will
be meeting with Randy hick at the Yukon
Wildlife Preserve hi boy to take on one
of the toughest animals of the
Yukon the
musox so a Randy where do you want us to
right there oh okay my parents arrived
last night I'm actually going to take
him out to The wfe Preserve today and
we're going to D A MUSC I don't even
think they've seen a MCX in real life
before maybe on TV Michelle's parents
have traveled from Indiana 3,000 M away
so it's a rare opportunity to see their
daughter in action okay Mom and Dad need
to bail out bail out we're going in the
musc's pen my parents have have never
seen me work before so they seem pretty
excited but I also have to focus on what
I'm doing so you know I'm trying to
visit with them a little bit and tell
them a bit about what I'm doing but you
know I'm getting ready to D A MUSC got
to get my game face on so you see that
bad boy over there yeah who looks like
just a sleeping lump don't let him fool
you yeah
sedating this qu ton Mammoth requires
keeping a safe
distance so Michelle's got her dart gun
locked and loaded good hunting
thanks picked his head
up I bet Michelle was scared the first
time she did
it a record setting heat wave in the
Yukon has Randy on high alert climbing
temperatures are tough on many animals
native to the
Yukon and for this musx fatigue could be
a Telltale sign that he's suffering from
heat
stress a condition that can quickly
become dangerous for an animal built to
withstand Sub-Zero
temperatures so our goals with this musx
today are to you know get a dart in him
quickly get him down as fast as possible
today we're really going against the
Heat muscs do not do well in any kind of
heat good this is this is good this is
close enough we need to make sure that
all the other vitals are okay and the
temperature staying steady because if it
starts to climb it's going to be really
hard to bring it
back come on buddy get
up oh yeah okay did we startle you he
just stood
up I think he's ready to bolt quick I'm
going I'm dirting them right
now oh look look at that stuck him
Michelle wanted to be a veterinarian
since she was 4 years old I think and
stuck to it all the way
[Music]
through
hey now with the clock ticking it's time
for Michelle and Randy to get down to
business and fast so it's about 8:30 so
I'd really like him reversing everything
else by 9:30 okay when you look at these
guys close up you can see why we're in
such a panic to get the anesthesia done
in the cool hours of the morning these
guys are basically covered in a blanket
of one of the warmest types of woolves
on Earth his body temperature could jump
up to a dangerous level you know within
10 15 minutes we have to be fast his
temperature's already climbing we really
got to
hustle let's get a heart rate and then
we can get started
MH to rule out a life-threatening
situation Michelle must make sure that
the the Bull's internal temperature
stays below
102° and that all of his vital signs are
in the
green I just can't I just can't get
another heart rate I mean I know it's
beating I just can't see it or find it
heart rate's really important too so
that's something I really have to
monitor there's a artery underneath the
chin I tried that couldn't get anything
there what's matter nothing but I just I
want to be sure the heart rate staying
steady and I can't seem to find it
anywhere
else so I'm actually going to get in
there and try and feel a an artery that
I can get a heart rate on because
they're just so hard
to a lot of them in the
way all right not getting anything there
either a weak heart rate might mean that
the musk ox is too deep under anesthesia
and his body temperature could
Skyrocket as an animal overheat you can
have proteins that are breaking down you
can have muscle damage the animal can
just kind of spiral into
shock it's getting hot quickly so I
decided to go ahead and give him just a
Teensy bit of reversal to bring him
around a reversal drug reverses the
effects of
anesthesia and hopefully will help
Elevate his heart rate back to
normal he's got a little bit refx a
little bit of a reflex he does okay and
it was all this guy needed to alleviate
Michelle's concerns so I'm not going to
worry about the heart anymore we're
going to worry about getting this stuff
done now Michelle can check for any
other signs of heat stress while Randy
gives him a
manicure but once you administer a
reversal agent even a small dose all
bets are off as to when this bull will
wake up do you know what the time is
that the muscs will be unconscious cuz
it's already
been 25 minutes really you want to check
his teeth stop yeah okay I don't know if
I can get my hand in there the way his
head's got all the weight on the jaw can
you
um I don't know is that even possible
how's your back his head probably weighs
like 100 lb yeah it's incredible okay
ready check his other
eye
[Music]
first
at the Yukon Wildlife Preserve Dr Oakley
and Randy race against the clock to
examine a 500lb musx bull Michelle's
parents watch from afar as The Bull
begins to stir okay
ready oh
pardon oh it moved didn't it
yeah come
on I was checking out his teeth and he
basically went and just blew muscock
spit all over me
I think a little curse word flew out of
my mouth um it's already Mom and
Dad everybody be
quiet okay he's panting
now that's a big
burp it sounded like thunder do you want
to just just give it to him just be done
y so as soon as he let us know that he
was getting light in the anesthesia we
realized we didn't have much time left I
took some blood samples had a good exam
there he finally cooled down to a great
temperature too and that's time to go
looks like it's trying to get up yeah
quick I think her and Randy both know
when to
move there's not too many times despite
all the dangerous animals and situations
that I work on that I get a bit of a
shake going and um yeah I was a little
jittery for a few minutes
with the exam complete this bull gets a
clean bill of health now he just needs
to stay out of the sun hopefully just
from our position it'll sort of force
him to go up into the trees where
there's more
shade oh there we go oh take your time
go up the shade buddy you're almost
there that's what we want awesome let's
go bye
buddy nothing to it right nothing to it
just had to wipe a little muscock spit
off my face
but I'll say one thing Michelle sure
leads a exciting
life think I need to go change my
drawers with a musk ox back on his feet
he heads for the shade to relax from one
generation to the next Michelle always
enjoys sharing her work with
family like mother-like daughter the vet
life can be a family business Michelle
and her daughter Willow are on their way
to help a baby cat where are we going to
dev's farm why cuzz it's an emergency
he's got a calf down um it was born last
night and he found it in the water
puddle this morning you are my official
helper right okay I'm ready don't let
him out Dev runs a farm outside of town
and for years he's been raising Hogs and
cattle I've known Dev for over 20 years
since I've been here he's a big Hulk of
a guy you know great big Yukon man but
boy does he have a soft heart a real sof
spot for the animals you hold one more
oh my
God
no yes I need to see your
baby you don't look real excited about
that huh the most dangerous animals are
often protective mothers do you want me
to run this skate no she'll go in there
by herself I can run it from here just
step back in here weighing 900 lb this
cow could easily Crush Michelle maybe
you calm down a bit hey come down a bit
Noe for everyone's safety devil will
separate mama from
baby come
on come
[Music]
on how are you doing see that she's just
shaking we had a calf that within 12
hours went from being nice and healthy
running around to laying in the water
and being weak and not getting up I it's
dry straw yeah the temperatures last
night were down around freezing so Dev
brought it into the barn often the first
sign of illness with a calf is
unwillingness to nurse have you got any
interest in sucking can you
suck oh you're trying it's weak though
and you're so cold so I'm looking at the
calf and it's definitely hypothermic it
seems quite dehydrated as well
dehydration can kill a calf in less than
24 4 hours okay Michelle must act fast
to figure out what's making this newborn
so sick there's something else that's
getting this calf down we have to think
about things like an umbilical infection
or even a septicemia I'm just looking
for signs to see if the calf is septic
cuz sometimes if they get eoli or
something they'll just go flat because
of that and sometimes when they're
septic you'll see like a red toxic line
along their gums or little hemorrhages
or signs of that it does look like the
calf's definitely has had diarrhea we
going to warm me up in a sec okay let me
see that jugular with the answer not
immediately clear Michelle turns to
stabilizing the calf so what I need to
do is get some warm Ivy fluids in it and
try to help bring up its body
temperature then I can figure out what's
going on okay these are just came on the
dryer okay great so good oh my
goodness just trying to find a vein he's
dehydrated and it's hard to get the vein
to pop up when they're kind of flat like
this got her yeah okay good and when
you're a small hobby Farm type you're
trying to make it profitable but at the
same time it's more than just a
paycheck they become like
pets now let me have listen to your
lungs for
you they cough on at
all definitely more gunk in there there
should be as soon as I listen to the
lungs and hear that rattle I know what's
going on it seems like maybe he's got a
little bit of
pneumonia actually feels pretty warm
like his body yeah but he's
shivering so maybe he's trying to build
a fever cuz your body will still shiver
to try and raise your body temperature
so if he's got you know some type of
pneumonia then he's probably trying to
crank it higher Michelle hopes she can
help the youngster regain its strength
and fight the infection with more
supportive care we'll give them at least
3 l of fluid over the next hour so we
can go do something else right now and
just see how he's doing in a bit there's
a couple cows Christian build up the pen
oh I saw that PR test you want to preg
test those it's actually common to be
called up to the farm to look at one
animal and then have two or three things
once you're there that the farmer
remembers oh there was also this case
and there's also that
hi perfect timing did you see how dirty
Bubba is yeah he needs a bath it's great
that I've got Willow here she loves
coming out to the farm she loves helping
care for the animals and she really
loves showing that she can keep up with
everybody else and do some hard work
yeah actually could you keep an eye on
the calf and make sure he doesn't get up
because I'll show you cuz then we can
not worry about that IV line getting
pulled out so today Willow is going to
be my right-hand
woman all right so if you can just make
sure if he tries to get up you let me
know cuz he could pull this IV out we
don't want that to happen all right okay
thanks H it's good to have her along and
it's never hard to get her to help
out okay so a preg check on a cow is
basically a rectal exam so go in deep
you got to have your shoulder glove no
shortage of lube of course only one more
to do after this all righty basically go
in and you try and find the uterus hello
who kick me okay
me so if you can just hold her tail up
like down at the base as much as
possible sometimes if they're quite
pregnant you'll basically bump into a
calf I'm shoulder deep in a cow it's in
there is in there and it's real big yeah
so oh and it just kicked
me she's a couple weeks but I can feel
the feet so okay
next mom the Cal's up
what C's up all right don't let him run
[Music]
around mom the C up what Dr Oakley and
her daughter Willow are working together
on a newborn calf that fell ill all
right don't let him run
around oh you little
bugger good thing you were checking eh
you're feeling lots better you little
stinker he's like jumping around oh oh
oh no no no it's a great sign that the
calf is up and you know feeling
energetic but we really want to run the
rest of the fluids through the calf hold
on baby hold on I had to do a wrestling
move on him to get her down did you just
in time for your match tomorrow huh so
it's good that Willow stopped it and we
got in there and could hold it down and
let it get the rest of the medications
that it needs little perkier now wants
to run away with the IV so I was just
going to if you can hold the back in I'm
going to try and get that IV off and cap
it that's quite a miracle eh Michelle
The Miracle Worker yeah right the
miracle of Ivy
fluids when all else fails give Ivy
fluids it's great this Baby's perked up
it's it just shows me he really needed a
little bit of supportive care so I'm
going to give him some antibiotics and
I'm sure he's going to be
fine oh he's trying a little bit devil
monitor the Cal overnight and call
Michelle if his condition worsens I'm
leaving the ivn just in case we need to
keep treating him he was hanging on to
it all righty you got to light now and
while he's up and got some energy be
good to get him back with his
mom
hopefully the calf will get enough on
its feet to lead a healthy life nursing
with Mom that's always a good way to end
the story as this mother and son
celebrate being back together Michelle
hits the road to help another
Duo back at her home Clinic Heating in
here Michelle is working with vet tech
Tracy and daughter Sierra today they're
meeting two very special dogs who play
in intrical part in their owner's
family so today I'm seeing uski his
owner Maggie she's concerned about uski
having some funny colored urine he's a
fantastic family pet but he's also a
service dog for Maggie son David so we
is sissies inside only one way to find
out David has um hurler syndrome which
is a really rare genetic condition um he
basically doesn't produce an enzyme that
breaks down carbohydrates at all green
light buki not only gives David physical
and mental support but he's also helping
to train Rocky to take his place by
David's side how many speed was that
that was 75
mph I got a check you got a
check the dogs help I think they help me
as much as they help him but the fact
that they help him is a huge help to me
cuz it's it's no picnic having a
medically fragile kid how are you come
on in it's going to rain Maggie and
David really rely on these dogs oh Davis
what's your new dog's name rocky rocky
hi Rocky has leopard spots service dogs
are trained to be in tune to their
people's needs o kisses oh on the lips
we just met when they're sick not like
they can just go rest in a corner
they've got people who are really
depending on them there you go good boy
what a good boy come on that's a big
jump I don't know waa you are so
athletic my good like hospital bed I
think he's fine all right so does he go
to hos the hospital with you and and you
take David and he goes that's awesome
and so is he basically there for support
then like kind of moral support he
alerts for pain OV exertion I didn't
teach him that and how does he alert
like he kind of at first it was barking
or sometimes he'll run back and forth
between like whoever's responsible for
David and David like hey check in going
incredible oh manki oi's been formally
working as a service dog about 5 years
now he actually has caught all kinds of
things he caught trigger finger eight
months ago David's fingers
are Ming I don't know how he knows
that's not volunt but I saw it happen 3
weeks ago we already have a surgery date
oh my God actually was a family pet um
he was two when David was born and I
think he knew before we did that
something was going on with him he
always was quick to come and comfort him
it's okay but they've just had the
sweetest Bond it's I can't imagine doing
the last 5 years without OSI you are
just sensitive to it all aren't you you
don't want anyone to be uncomfortable if
lki can teach Rocky how to pick up on
all those little changes in David's body
that we've seen I think that's that more
than that part you know okay so what's
going on with this bloody ear let me
hear a bit about how that's been going
um so it was a little while after we
took him swim in last week and I just
kind of periodically check from time to
time and it was super dark um and the
sample that I got is really funky color
it was dark red like towards the end
like I have the samp on the cooler I'd
like to see that when if we can hold on
them if you want to grab it the coloring
Clarity of Us's urine could hold
important Clues to what's making him
sick ooh okay yeah that's really Brown
huh doesn't smell very nice doesn't look
real nice so we're going to hang tight
on this a normal urine sample is usually
pale yellow clear uski sample is quite a
dark color it actually looks like
there's blood in it and that can be a
sign that there's something more serious
going on can you hold that down leg
above the elbow good boy this one that's
good there that's a good that's a good
point oh my goodness what the heck it's
okay's to get down I know you're worried
a so the first thing we're going to do
is an ultrasound of Us's bladder what
does he have to do does he have to hold
still
Yes I want to look to see if there's any
masses if there's any crystally kind of
material so there's a lot of stuff in
the bladder so do you see that the black
circle at the top there's a lot of stuff
in there that shouldn't be there I can
actually see a mass um but I also see a
little bit of crystally formation in the
urine is it a bladder tumor which can be
very serious or a kidney stone that's so
white it looks Stone to me you know what
I mean like hope it'd be better than
like the alternative that would sure be
awesome okay everybody Hold Steady okay
we're going to go in hold still using
the ultrasound to guide a needle is
inserted directly into Us's bladder so
we're taking the urine sample right out
of Us's bladder oh I got the teeniest
bit perfect be teenus the nice thing
about that is you get your best sample
and chance to get good cells it could be
looked at by The Specialist okayi sorry
about this but this is a good
distraction a blood sample will also be
sent to the lab good boyi wait there
okay so I'm going to send out the
samples to a pathologist and see if we
can get an answer on what's causing it
oh my goodness that's so much better oh
you're such a good boy oh good boy all
done all done all done yeah I I hope
it's not cancer but I know I know that's
hard work huh you did good there's
generally like a dollar limit on what I
would spend on a vet bill but he's
earned some extra Grace there so we'll
talk about results as soon as we get
those back on the blood and the urine
okay and we'll make a plan from there
okay all right all right you have a safe
trip
back
please David said he's he's his best
friend but he's more than that I think
you too you know he's been a protector
he's been just
he just helps with everything really we
really got lucky bui's test results will
be back in a week until then all David
can do is
[Music]
wait the test results are in David and
his father Dan returned to find out the
the condition of their service
dogi hi therei how's he been doing good
good okay is it okay if I put him up on
the table all right come here oi scoop
you up when he last saw Dr Oakley there
was a mass in his bladder kind of heavy
he's getting pretty old is he that's all
right oi you good boy okay let's have a
real gentle feel here
oy yeah so I still feel something there
good stuff good boy's urine was sent to
a lab to determine if the mass was
cancer or Stones so um when Maggie
brought him in a few weeks ago I took a
sample of urine out right out of his
bladder and we sent it in and um what
we're hearing back is there was no
definitive sign of cancer cells which
was really good they won't say 100% but
the sample we sent didn't have any in it
what we're seeing is most likely Stones
so bladder stones that are causing the
bleeding and the blood in this urine
even though that doesn't sound so good
it's definitely the better of the two
you know Stones we can try to change his
diet and get rid of them that way and
they actually have diets that will try
and Shrink those stones so our treatment
for now is going to be to change his
diet and give him things that will try
and break down those stones and he can
just urinate them out that would be the
best case scenario did uski go with you
to the hospital yeah fantastic and did
he do okay all think so you think so
David's a big part of yki and 's a big
part of David and I think David kind of
understands he sees that uski is doing
better too all right well thanks for
bringing uski in he you want to
jump good boy he must be feeling better
he is you know you can see that Dan's
relieved too that you know his boy is
going to have his dog and his dog is
going to be there for him we'll be in
touch okay you let me know how he's
doing we'll see him in a couple months
okay thank you you're welcome and you
take good care ofi okay David yeah good
luck guys bye
you know it's such an important
relationship and I'm so glad I could
help them along with it thanks to
Michelle's care this family leaves with
peace of mind and a healthy
dog Michelle's on her way to visit her
longtime friend and goat breeder Pauline
Patton whose goat herd is growing
Pauline has a lot of goats and actually
four years ago I came out here with
Willow and left with two goats and um we
had our goats for for several years we
lost Kate last
year Kate was a goat Willow had raised
herself but sadly she was attacked and
in the end didn't make it come on
Kate for the Oakley family it was a
tough
loss it's been a year close to a year
now and um there's been some time
there's been some healing and we're
thinking about getting another one get a
Pikachu one that's getting ready to have
bids yeah you're the her name is Annie
and she's as big as a house right now
she's very shy so I'll uh I'll go in
okay you're you're welcome to go in but
just stay the Ed Annie come on come here
Annie banan come on she can't resist
isn't she huge oh my gosh she she looks
awesome go Annie an Alpine Nubian goat
is pregnant and do any day now when she
came walking out of her pen I was it was
hard not to be like like wo you know
because she's literally I swear as wide
as she is long like uh she's huge oh she
looks like she's getting ready like her
Volva looks pretty relaxed and her bag
is full he oh her otter is just and that
has only happened in the last 24 hours
you are wide load you need a wide load
sign
on and I heard you're a very good mommy
very attentive huh she is so she has no
trouble nursing the four babies before
you know what we didn't give her that
opportunity because they're all going to
be competing cuz they only have two
teeths right and so I didn't want them
competing so we took two and we hand
raised them are you ready for this year
um yep we are we have our box got the
play pan ready yeah once all the kids
are born and are running around here um
definitely bring Willow back I can't
guarantee we'll leave the yard with with
any good luck with Annie yeah thanks for
I hope you don't need to call me for any
help but you know if you need help I'm
happy to I'm there for you secretly I
want to come and take three or four home
with me but we'll see how
[Music]
go for Dr Oakley family time is
everything she takes her daughter Willow
to check on the baby goats who were born
safely so excited to go see the goats
uhhuh
yeah so today we're at Pauline Patton's
place at the goat farm I told told
Willow about being out here and she was
pretty disappointed that she didn't get
to come and Willow's been talking about
getting another goat you know I've been
thinking about oh wouldn't it be nice to
have them around again guys we're doing
well I bet you know why we're here I
gave Michelle a call this morning and
let her know that all four goats had
arrived I definitely wanted Willow to
have some exposure milking the goats and
just spending some time with the little
kids this one is Lizzy come and pick him
up there you go and here Michelle we
don't want should be left out this is
whiskey oh my gosh a look at them come
and sit down adorable you had four hey
we've got four of them yeah as as you
know mother only has two teeth so we
wanted to hand raise two of them cuz I
don't want to have a run yeah and I
don't want to see competition too late I
had an
accident that's okay I don't mind I can
will are you into milking the goats cuz
the goats are really hungry oh yeah yeah
I'd like one of these but I have to get
my dad on board with it so what you're
going to do Lizzy look oh there you go
there you go then it goes in
go she says I'm happy now a I can just
see Willows you know in love
again uh we'd have to get Shane talked
into that hey you think you could talk
Dad into more goats mhm we'll just say
that we're getting a guy goat but I want
a girl goat so we'll just say that a Geo
he'll never notice and then we'll just
like like if it gets pregnant then we'll
just say that it was accidentally a girl
the whole
time number two no no relax she gets so
excited yeah make sure the milk is in
the nipple there you go you're an old
pro at this Willow they're just babies
they're only a few days old so they're
going to stay with their mom for you
know a good month 6 weeks or so and then
they'll be looking for homes for them so
cu got some time to work on Shane oh man
they are just so
cute for many owners their animals are
part of the
family I'm just heading to Sarah grams
uh she called me about her 3-year-old
pot belly pig he's had some Behavior
changes over the past winter that can
actually be linked to a physical problem
so I'm going to go over there now and
give him a give him a checkup here we
are oh wao
whoo well howdy typically you can Farm a
little bit of
everything hey Sarah hi how's it going
nice to finally meet you yeah good to
meet you and this is my assistant Tony's
technician giving me a hand meet you we
could start with uh
Batman he's my pig okay my pig is named
Batman because he's a Super Pig
Batman Batman see there he
is oh hey buddy hi honey who's the
handsomest Pig I've ever
seen pop bellied pigs can be trained to
use litter boxes leading many owners
like Sarah to welcome them into their
homes he's a house Pig he's very very
smart if someone knocks on my door he's
right up there with the dogs barking and
he's a great guy look at that little
tushy he comes on two three hour hikes
with us and the dogs we call him
Adventure Pig but this young Pig's
adventuring days may be coming to an end
Sarah has noticed some changes in her
companion's superhero ways used to come
inside all the time yeah and he would
come up the stairs and scratch at the
door when he wanted to come in but this
winter he just never came inside like he
wouldn't even come up the stairs like
nothing the first thing I think of when
an animal doesn't want to go places that
it used to go is that animal maybe
having some Mobility ISS is shoes and
Batman is no thin Pig the average weight
for a potbellied pig is around 150 lb he
is definitely even for a pig a little
overweight maybe 170 you think so his
belly is pretty much dragging the ground
I don't understand how he's so big
though I'm not sure what he's getting in
terms of scraps but everything yeah so
he definitely shouldn't get any meat he
shouldn't get anything fatty pigs will
fill their bellies with just about
anything including insects trash and
animal carcasses but to keep a trim pet
their diet should be limited to a feed
designed specifically for pigs with
vegetables for snacking Batman
definitely needs to shed a few pounds
but there's another thing that might
inhibit his ability to go where he wants
and that's if he has any problems with
his feet I'm just checking out his feet
right now he om M and a big
G Batman has hooves that are quite
overgrown that's going to make him not
feel like moving around as much that's
going to cause uh more weight gain and
the weight gain is going to cause more
abnormal wear so you get in a bit of a
catch 22 and it's just going to lead to
a lame Pig and you will get arthritis
developing because of that and then it's
a really tough thing to try and deal
with to get him moving again Michelle
must sedate Batman and trim his
Hooves come here
oh just need to get them up in a corner
here and pin them in the
wall
watch I don't get
you
nope I wasn't quick enough on the
injection all I did was make him mad
maybe we can try one more time over here
oh don't let him get out
though can can you jam it up in here so
he
can't
sorry I think we need your way don't let
him out don't let him
[Music]
out okay I think we need your way don't
let him out Dr Oakley is trying to
sedate Batman the pig but despite his
size he's giving her a run for her money
here sweetheart
look
uh-oh mister I'm going to get a clean
needle I think we have to do the grab by
the
legs come here
okay okay the injections finally in it's
basically a a 5-second incident but it
certainly hurts his feelings and he and
he lets us know about that okay there we
go move a little
easier let's get busy on those
feets see how it's like kind of curved
around there b they can start to like
poke into the back of their foot it
hasn't done that yet which is good it's
a really good thing we're dealing with
Batman's feet now instead of having
these long kind of skis he will have a
nice proper angle and he'll be able to
cruise around more and he'll probably
keep them more and down more on his own
okay those look kind of lovely they do
if I do say so myself he'll be a much
happier Pig yep with his feet back in
shape Batman should be able to climb
stairs and hang out in the house once
again again oh are you waking up now hey
buddy how's it going good boy oh okay
okay
buddy there's that good boy oh my
goodness sure get up by that straw
Batman's just waking up from the
anesthesia he's not too sure where he is
need block that off cuz he's going right
for it oh he sure is here grab him
back there we go n here there's your mom
you're okay okay he kind of Tri out a
little bit wondering who are these new
people you know what just happened to
them we're not going to bug you I'm not
even here finally Batman shows signs
he's regaining his
senses there you
are get off drunk
Pig Batman definitely does not like his
hoof trim he is definitely going to hold
a grudge with me after today but he'll
get over it Michelle will come back at a
later date to give Batman weigh in and
check on his progress we'll be in touch
awesome thank you take
[Music]
care while enjoying some motherdaughter
bonding time Michelle and Willow get a
fun surprise a video from Lydia oh some
good news from friends back home it says
something about her turkey oh oh was a
video let me pull over and we'll have a
look at it Willow just got an email from
her friend Lydia and Lydia brought in
her turkey skimpy to see me like it had
a an injured
leg turkey look at Turkey hi Willow um I
just wanted to give you an update on
skimpy a he looks good his legs looking
better and he he likes to walk around
now with all his other turkey
friends awesome it's great to get
updates from patients and from clients
and that's the great part about
practicing small town in the nor is
everyone's in touch thanks for helping
him get better bye a that's so nice know
if I don't see them right away they're
going to send me a picture they're going
to send me a video and I just love that
about my job looks like skimpy is doing
great yeah till
Thanksgiving W we're hoping for better
for skimpy I think he's going to end up
being a house
turkey after all her work is done
Michelle's on the hunt for a a fun
family activity fortunately she doesn't
have to look far this part of the Yukon
averages 5 ft of snow in the winter
which means the spring melt brings some
prime mud real estate and the Oakleys
take full advantage today we're going to
to a little ATV in and uh we're going to
go just out by our house and there's a
few mud holes there too so we might do a
little
[Music]
bogging oh my God
no living in Yukon you can go out on a
day like today and uh find a little mud
hole and be entertained in you know 50
yards of mud it's uh you can't you can't
beat
[Music]
that that was awesome fantastic
there
uh I think Willow gets the prize for
being the muddiest she's and uh she's
working at it some
more you don't need to pay money for
this Willow looks
like ooh that's scary she looks like a
swamp
monster in my
bath Willow she'd rather roll around
that mud than take a bath I'm sure she's
out there just having a great
time oh my God you are the cutest little
mud monster I've ever seen and don't
even think about it i' love no no
hugging no hugging a
willow let's get back to the house no
one's going in the house nobody goes in
the house nobody goes in the house all
boor now everyone go in the house every
just book it into the house this kind of
stuff is a blast I mean you can't do
this in a city somewhere this is why we
live here these are the trade-offs you
know we don't get a lot of other City
things but this is pretty fun good clean
family
[Music]
fun